newsmax host greg kelly
has an idea for unifying the country
just pardon all the january 6 trump riot
defenders joe biden could really bring
everybody together
if he just said hey you know what
we're going to let you all go we're
going to pardon all of you now how that
would unite the country i don't know but
let's listen to what greg kelly had to
say critical opponents political enemies
in jail you know if he wanted to unify
this country on january 21st after he
made that solemn pledge his whole soul
was in it to unify us he could have gone
to that jail and made arrangements for
them to be let go
[Laughter]
how would that even unify the country
like most of the country
it's shocking that the country's ever
really united on anything but most of
the country is already united that the
riots were bad
it was trumpists who did it the
perpetrators should be prosecuted so how
would saying we're gonna let all you
guys go
how would that unite the country it
seems it would be an incredibly dumb
thing to do maybe he meant instead of
unifying this is how to capitulate to
the extreme right just let all of them
go and meanwhile remember that they
preach personal responsibility in all of
it they say we have to be responsible
for our actions we have to take
seriously when we make a decision we
have ultimate agency we're the ultimate
agents of our lives and sometimes those
actions come with consequences but
actually the president should just let
all of us go what and and the other kind
of layer to this that's weird and i
don't expect a host on newsmax to really
understand this or take it seriously
anyway is
if they did nothing wrong as is another
narrative
then why would they need to be pardoned
if they didn't do anything wrong they'll
just be found not guilty they will never
stop claiming
that the other side needs to do
something what about not rioting what
about that as a way to stay out of
trouble don't riot to begin with and
then you wouldn't have this problem in
the from the get-go
they
every principal that they claim to
espouse goes in the
third element of the bathroom the toilet
as soon as it's inconvenient and now
it's personal responsibility well all of
a sudden it's up to biden it's up for
whoever to give them these get out quite
literally get out of jail free cards not
gonna happen and it actually wouldn't
unify the country it would do the
opposite because most of the country
shockingly actually thinks these rioters
did do something wrong and they need to
be held accountable
as many of you know i take my snacks
very seriously i avoid excess sugar and
junk food and so when i want something
sweet
i go to our sponsor monk pack monk pack
makes my favorite granola bars and nut
and seed bars if you're doing keto it
works just one gram of sugar or less
only two to three net carbs under 150
calories the flavors are delicious sea
salt dark chocolate that's my favorite
you've got your coconut cocoa chip
you've got your caramel sea salt the
texture the flavors this is a beautiful
granola bar and then you've got monk
packs nut and seed bars which are more
crunchy if you're craving something like
a crunchy chocolate candy bar monk pack
is the perfect thing to grab instead
same taste same experience none of the
carbs and sugars and calories get 20 off
your first order at monkpack.com using
the code pacman at checkout the link is
down below